hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and I'm joined here
today by Richard fetter he's an
economics professor at Ohio University
in Ohio and author of several books
including going broke by degree why
college costs too much and you have a
serve an interesting counterintuitive
take on higher education policy in this
country that if I'm not mistaken the
government in trying to make it
affordable has made it too expensive can
you explain how that works yeah it takes
a larger percentage of a family's income
to go to college today than it did 30 40
50 years ago for almost all Americans
now that's not true of most things that
we buy it's not true of airline travel
it's not true a lot of buying
automobiles with economic growth things
usually get less burdensome with the
passage of time but with higher ed it's
the opposite and part of the reason a
huge part of the reason is because
governmental policies while a
well-intended no doubt have had sort of
an effect of increasing the demand for
higher education the number of kids
wanting to go to college without having
the same impact on the supply of higher
education meaning the prices have been
pushed up so tuition costs have gone up
at twice the rate of inflation for 34
years going up faster than medical cost
why wouldn't the law of supply and
demand suggest that people would start
universities because it's profitable
well that is exactly what is starting to
happen but the main obstacle of that
have been accreditation rules various
governmental restrictions governments
refusing to provide the financial aid
that they provide for kids to go to
government schools to go to particularly
the new proprietary or for-profit
institutions which I think have a great
deal of promise and are growing rather
fast in spite of all of these obstacles
and that's where maybe the future lies
but right now we
government drops money out of airplanes
over campuses all those campuses use
that money and efficiently they're mean
evilly organized they're not disciplined
by market forces unlike the rest of the
economy or most of the rest of the
economy and as a consequence consequence
just like medical care costs are rising
and rising and rising should states or
governments have as a policy goal to
increase the number of college graduates
I think that's a questionable objective
it's a lot about sounding objective but
I think we have to ask ourselves what
are the benefits of a college education
what are the costs of a college
education is the piece of paper we give
people called a diploma really necessary
for a lot of the work that goes on in
the workforce today 12% of the mail
carriers in the United States today now
have bachelor's degrees do you really
need a bachelor's degree to deliver the
mail in 1970 only 3% it is that suddenly
mail delivery has become much more
intellectually challenging than it did
40 years ago I don't think so
we're having more and more people who
are getting college degrees that are
having trouble getting jobs that are
really related to the intellectual
development such as it is that they get
while they're in universities so I'm
wondering whether we maybe have started
to over invest in higher education it's
a view by the way held by some other
scholars charles Murray being most
notable among them that that's many
people going to college don't have the
cognitive skills for college they're ill
prepared for college and if they do get
a degree it's often watered down and
we're just spending a lot of money to
give a person a piece of paper the obama
administration has proposed making Pell
grants something akin to an entitlement
what's your reaction about the wisdom of
that I I think it's highly questionable
first of all why should philosophically
I wonder why should government
be paying for higher education the only
justifications for government paying for
higher education is one yes
equal access we want to help people move
up the economic ladder that's the
American you gala Terry and ideal that's
an argument the other argument is that
education somehow these spillover
effects that are positive that if one
person goes to college that that tends
to promote economic growth and all all
of my research shows that these are
myths actually the more we spend on cut
more the state's spend on colleges and
universities the lure of the rate of
economic growth they have not the higher
the lower the rate of economic growth
they have and as far as equal
opportunity we have actually a smaller
pet percentage of low income people in
the college population today than we did
thirty five years ago before Pell grants
and before most of these federal
programs so they haven't worked the way
they were supposed to and some of the
notion that somehow we ought to expand
them when they haven't really been very
effective in the first place
strikes me as bizarre put off that's the
course putting in society issues like
the huge federal deficits and the
irresponsibility of the federal
government borrowing huge sums of money
and all these other macroeconomic issues
is putting those aside how and when did
you arrive at your interest in free
markets and limited government
principles and libertarianism well I'm
an economic historian by training and I
studied economic history and I did not
come at things from a libertarian
perspective or even conservative
perspective fact I have some fairly
progressive left-wing credentials in my
family uh
but the more I looked into things the
more I saw that countries with free
markets relatively stable money supplies
limited government tended to be more
prosperous grow more people mark I did a
lot of work out migration where did
people who did they move from West
Germany to East Germany or did they move
from East Germany into Western
what site when people try to cross the
Berlin Wall and get shot at that wasn't
going from west to east it was going
from east to west the West had something
resembling you know a market economy the
East had something that was quite
different
I found that markets worked and I must
do some empirical work the more
regressions I ran the more I found that
people that responded to market forces
and market forces had a positive effect
on society then of course I you know
start reading people like Rothbard and
many other thinkers who said much the
same thing and that probably reinforced
my thinking on the matter looking at the
current climate what do you see is sort
of the biggest fear that you have on the
horizon in terms of public policy or the
economy and then also what's your
biggest hope for things getting better
well I think we are in a crossroads as a
nation we as bob Pyxis wrote in his book
crisis of lieth on we have gone through
a sort of certain critical periods in
history where there's been a big upsurge
in government activity that seems to not
reverse itself we had that during the
Great Depression
someone's and we had it again in the
1960s to some extent seems to me we're
starting the possibility going through
another wave of that with the Obama
administration we are we have government
is controlled by people who are
fundamentally distrustful of capitalism
in some cases downright hostile to it
they're socialists and I don't mean that
as a pejorative term is just a fact and
I that's very concerning will they
prevail or not will they be able to
adopt the agenda i I don't however
having said that getting to the last
half-year question I have some hope
because first of all I teach 20 21 22
year-old kids and they are less
spittin with the socialist impulse the
government impulse are they they are
more open to
the possibilities that markets have
power and can do good for society then
perhaps many people realize and I really
think in the long run the Obama
experiment will prove unsuccessful and
there will be a counter-revolution if
you like the the current political
environment on the right is is
unfortunately pretty murky and without
leadership but in time that will change
and so I think long run perhaps we are
not so bad on that a hopeful note will
end there thank you very much this is
Matt Welch for recent TV